questionné à fabrice pour terminer mais
c'est vous votre mot préféré mon mot
préféré c'est vraiment un seul mot vous
me limiter à un motard non mais vous
faites vite un vrai j'avais très très
vite croquis le mot vous détestez
médiocre votre drogue favorite la
répétition sur une scène de théâtre
le son le bruit que vous aimez la voix
d'un acteur immense d'une actrice
immense donc entre parenthèses j'ai été
servi à l'isi le son le bruit comme en
déclin ne brille que je déteste les
mobylettes qui vont très peu vite et que
les gars des blocs comme on appelle ça
rigolait ont dégonflé
c'est à pau à pau à bayonne par exemple
un énorme bruit qui est une agression
absolument tour joueront gros mot
blasphème favori espèce de petit fientes
nous femmes pour 800 nouveaux billets de
banque pour illustrer un nouveau billet
de banque je peux vous en donner deux
balzac pour les 500 francs 100 francs et
rhin et arthur rimbaud pour les 100
francs arthur rimbaud pour l'ambiguïté
de la fin de sa vie quand il travaillait
avec les noirs en afrique pour le
monospace et des ententes voulait même
pays ne voulais même plus savoir ce
qu'il avait écrit comme ces sublimes et
bien le cas limités je n'aurais pas aimé
faire ben je vais faire un peu de peine
à ma maman mais j'aurais pas aimé de
coiffeur la plante l'arbre l'animal dans
lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné la
plante l'animal dans lequel j'aurais été
je vais être réincarné c'est la question
non non mais moi je répète une pièce en
développement junte et oublie moi je
dirais c'est très beaux arbres qu'on
voit à nice avec les choses non mais non
les tous les trucs qu'on les palmiers et
les paroles parce que comme disait paul
valéry ils ont le ils ont ils ont le
sens de la chute
enfin si dieu existe
si dieu existe qu'aimeriez vous après
votre mort l'entendre vous dire avoue
fabrice luchini et bien j'aimerais
qu'ils me disent deux choses j'ai le
droit à 2 oui oui première chose dieu
est amour donc tout va bien je vomit les
tièdes donc encore une fois tout va bien
et troisième chose il y à une lecture de
maître eckhart par michel bouquet à 18
heures